volete sapere come mi sono ridotto così
vi lascio al video e faccio prima
perfetto ragazzi amo su berdych i verdi
king land che è una roba tipo saper di
burger riesco a casa capisco un cazzo di
francesi suoi esseri space por come
serio io ho scelto il tedesco da
studiando ogni francese quindi non mi
cristo nata addosso se non lo parlo
vedete fatiha perdonatevi era gaspard de
felice ma che non sia fans e comincia
allora ragazzi è stato definito uno dei
migliori giochi per oculus triste io
adesso voglio vederlo casa sta roba
cos'è sto coso ragazzi sto già gasando
dove che arriva quando i cali a martin
garris questa roma che 30 flemma beh ma
[ __ ] alla gf questo voi capito
guardi burger
credo che debbano andare al board di
boehringer di quale c'è il bar di burgas
è bellissimo tagliamo a sto bar di
bologna a charge mente in corso perfetto
credo che sia caricamente in corso non
sono un genio sono in una moto posso
guidare giorno che bello 6 ragazzo mio
vero baxter ha mai preso un hamburger
sì ma non mi sventolare sto coso che più
piccolo del tuo bene cosa fare
ragazzi se c'è un pennuto che è trovato
la casa incazzato e così ecco bravo
porca [ __ ] sono visti in faccia
ascolta video grosse deve seguire un
pennuto perché ste cazzo di macchine
de martin giuro che le faccio nere se
devi seguire un premuto perché tappo
tutto un hamburger cioè ma ripigliati
già ce l'hai la patente
ok io non c'era la partenza e quindi
vita due centri
c'era c'era il treno libri gira gira
bravissimo bravo zio super favore suo
bravo grazie ai ragazzi mi prende
malissimo perché lo dico già e dove
stiamo andando bene
forse perché si trovi una scritta fine
della strada tu cosa fai se vai addosso
sei un deficiente
buongiorno guarda non sto giocando a
skyrim
però tu sei bello come i draghi mai mai
mai mai mai mai mai mai bravo bravo è la
madonna è la madonna che cos'è sta roba
briganti esageratissimo sociale lo
prendiamo sto a tutto sto casino per un
hamburger hayes vorrei solo farvi capire
se c'è un pennuto gigantesco che cos'è
con la roba lì braga mi chiami sembra
cosa no fermo fermo fermo fermo per
numero e vabbè cellulare non ci ha presi
si apprezzi che idiota ragazzi già
possiamo fare
l'ama è cos'è indiana jones dei ragazzi
mi convince sganciato si è sganciata la
moto è normale
si ok ascolta e va bene sono ancora sto
ancora non davanti come cazzo cose non
so il motore io ho zio mi ripiglio no
sono quando cazzo fa merda ragazzi sono
messa ma lison da solo che fa chi è
accatastato giro sulle montagne russe
giusto per chiedere cos'è sta roba
l'ha portato i pulcini ma che tesoro
guarda che non si dagli hamburger ei
pulcini di ota eccoti quasi fai da te lo
guarda sei un figo dell'amat fattelo
dire se un figo ma è un tesoro pieno di
lattine finito fantastico è stato è
stato veramente veramente bello come il
gioco più bello che abbia mai fatto non
seriamente stato figo l'unica [ __ ]
cosa che non ho capito che cosa serve
questo coso qua dietro vedo non vedo
delle sfere del drago ragazzi ci mette
nel sedere drago vicino evochiamo
sherlock hulk ragazzi a parte tutto
siamo su project job seeker genica che
pronuncia sexy gioco però tour swift se
non si fosse notato che ci sono delle
sfere del drago non se ne metta non so
che cosa c'è scusa eh sì l'ho fatta ok
ho cliccato qualcosa non so cosa horning
intenso gameplay giocare se hai problemi
cardio vascolare madonna cosa mi sparano
addosso project jump scherza troppo di
horror quindi credo che cos'è ma salva e
buongiorno e lo caccio è un problema
presenta un'esperienza di brandon px
ragazzi sappiamo che andare a linciare
se muoio fate partire o devo guardare
titoli di
introduzione per tutta la vita mi carica
sembra skyrim oh mio dio il triangolo a
bell inizio se mettono la palla da
discoteca e più divertente perfetto
ragazzi posso muovere chiuse quando mi
giro non vedo più un cazzo perfetto come
ragazzi ed è bello è bello come gioco in
partenza soprattutto posso andare di qua
ma chi è bello ragusa sta roba è una
storia del drago una ricetta ok cosa
sono quei o mio dio per cui l'ha colpito
le navicelle spaziali qualcuno che spara
altre tre sfere del drago ragazzi siano
già 4 vai bene o dio vieni qua che mi
servi di ogni giorno share
ma mi ascom ascoltato la mia richiesta
mi ha fatto avere un'arma fantastico ma
posso sparare
adoro questo [ __ ] ciò contro smetti
permetti tool uribe arriva una di quelle
botte che manco mia nonna natale con le
lasagne hachiro sociale soprattutto non
lo voglio scoprire anzi facciamo così
dissi ma solo perché non vedo una sega
se no mori bastardo ho vinto ho vinto io
ho vinto io chi sono sti deficienti io
io io vedo che tu sei un figo lo vedo se
vuoi possiamo giocare insieme la voi
quest'arma guardami girati a shock
tornata a prendermi luridi strong perché
ne avete lasciato qua sotto che brutti
che sono mio dio
signori bile fatti un make up qualcosa
che mi segue porca put mi fanno prendere
il colpo di goldbet sente di me vabbè
cosa siete gol un gol un fermo fermo gol
perché è strada è morto è morto
cos'è lo fa altra arma al cos'è questo
non c'è granate ragazzi
lo so che belle che figo 9 st casa
fighissima sì però non fa un cazzo di
danno mi spiegate il senso morire è
morto è morto ma non fa niente gli danno
sarò basta che palle
russo anche la nonna guarda che
incredibile via cavo o mio dio e ma se
gli autografi frutto di prima vasto il
bene proprio sul bene ecco bravo e ditte
bene il punto debole sempre che non
farmi venire il torcicollo profilo degli
altri perfetto
sono morto su questo morendo non si
sarebbe così i valori il nostro nord a
son tornato a checkpoint prof ho capito
che i burger king qua scarseggia e
quindi dovete mangiare che però non
cagate ville e balla me guarda che roba
incredibile troppa gente basta a tutti
uguali sì posti due mazze ott certo ma
facciamo chiedere anche un meteorite già
che ci siamo tra la bufera tra che
accusa però project jobs che ho finito
beh basta non ne potevo più ragazzi è
stato orribile
grazie cagata assurda però vorrei capire
una cosa lega ma le navicelle iniziale
che cazzo serviva grazie per aver
provato la prima demo di project jumps
che raffigura notizia perché sono malato
di mente se non l'avrei mai fatto che
ora da ragazzi se il video vi è piaciuto
ok sono i giochi horror che mi fanno
questa cosa quindi ragazzi servito è
piaciuto come al solito è stato
lungamente gli piace ogni mi piace che
mi mandate uno shampoo per rimettermi a
posto i capelli forse dovresti discreti
non ci rivediamo nel prossimo video
belle ragazze